everybody welcome to live coding with
Jessie I'm Jessie and today we're gonna
do all kind of stuff so I gave it a very
title of this video a very vague name
because we got a lot of stuff to do
I wasn't sure what we were gonna get
done we're gonna have time to do so
let's just start out I want to give you
some updates we we now have a lot of
issues open I set up a project like a
Kanban board within the github repo let
me let me switch over and so I can show
you what I'm talking about
so I started a project here we have a
bunch of cards now with issues I can
make a card quickly convert it into an
issue and then once that issue I'm not
sure I think what's the issue is opened
or something it goes to in progress and
then once it's completed it goes to done
automatically which is kind of cool
so if you haven't used this yet just
click on the project's tab on your
github repo and if you select the
automated Kanban board
it sets up a lot of it for you it gives
you some some different steps to do so
tonight issues of PR so we've done some
of these but anyway I've used this on a
previous project before I thought I'd
set it up so we now have a lot of issues
if you want to you know contribute these
are broken down into most of them are
very simple tasks very small things so
have at it we may actually fix some of
these today we'll see how it goes so I'm
gonna move this back over we don't need
it right now
hey everybody let's see some some highs
there in the live chat hopefully let me
know if you all got the notification on
YouTube because yesterday I got my
notification after I had already ended
the stream so alright it looks like I
did get a notification on my phone two
minutes ago so I did I didn't get the
earlier notification like usually
happens so anyway sometimes I think it
depends on how late in the day I
schedule is all right so on the screen
right now we can see you know basically
where we left off at yesterday and I
want to show you some of what I've been
working on Oh before I forget I have a
new video up on my youtube channel so
check I think I have a link in the
description to my channel check it out
it's my video review of the react
nanodegree program so I know I said that
that video was going to be coming months
ago and I finally did it so it's there
it's short video you know less than 10
minutes just so my thoughts on the
nanodegree program which i've already
shared a lot of it with you all in the
stream but now there's a short video
where everything is kind of summed up so
if you haven't done the program yet
you're thinking about it you know maybe
it'll help you make your decision so
what I've been working on let's go to
our Microsoft there we go our sequel I
always remember forget the name of this
sequel operations studio I think that's
it we're gonna go to see cooperation
studio here I'm going to show you what
I've been looking at so I keep going
through this is our database just for
everybody that hasn't been full
since the beginning of this project just
to catch you all up we have a database
right now for the current University
website that's a sequel server database
and we're using a content management
system called Ektron which is pretty
outdated the company doesn't even exist
anymore
so we want to move all the data out and
we want to automate as much as possible
we want to avoid having to copy and
paste things so we're moving out
we're not just dumping it all we're
moving it out section by section we're
using the wordpress api to put the data
in to a my sequel database and then
users you know administrators will be
able to edit things through a wordpress
admin panel but we won't really mess
that much with wordpress the site the
public facing site but that users will
see is going to be a react site and
we're gonna get the data from graph QL
so right now the step that I'm working
on is checking out the data saying what
info we have and then I'm going to move
it all over to WordPress it's going to
be slightly different than the way we've
done this with some other pieces of data
so these are all news articles and they
go back for four years I want to bring
them all over so we have a nice archive
but what I'd like to do is keep the
publish date and make that the publish
date for for in WordPress I think
that'll be really useful in fact I mean
I think that's necessary right there'll
be no context at all for when these
things were posted or how relevant they
are anymore unless we bring the data
over somehow
so the last thing I was trying to do was
figure out what format I need the date
to be in in the WordPress API and I just
had that info up here so let me
this over so we don't have to go through
too many screens so we can add the date
in here
let's see string day time ISO 8601 okay
so what I was thinking might be the
easiest way to figure out so like this
ISO 8601 that doesn't mean anything to
me right now I need to see what the date
actually looks like so I'm gonna check
out the API and see what the API gives
us when we want to see a published date
let me start my Pomodoro timer and we're
gonna work on this for 25 minutes and
I'm gonna have minimal interaction with
the live chat I'll glance at it
occasionally then I'm gonna take five
minutes and it's I'm just gonna go to a
live chat check out your comments answer
any questions we'll go back and do some
more work and we'll just kind of go back
and forth and see how things go I want
to get at least two 25-minute sessions
of work on the project at the end of
that I'll answer any remaining questions
or read out comments so you know
whatever questions you might have for me
you let put them in the in the live chat
and I'll please be patient I will get to
them alright so let's go with one
alright this works alright so our date
is going to be in this format
[Music]
this is gonna be tricky a little bit
tricky all right so here's what we have
in terms of a date and I'm showing all
the data here because I just wanted to
see what was available normally we would
want to instead of an asterisk here for
the the query we wouldn't want to you
know narrow it down so we didn't have
all this stuff and when we import it
we're not going to import everything
which can afford a few things but we
have a date created we have an edit date
I don't think we have a published date
last crota yeah we don't have a
published date so I think we're gonna
have to go with they created must edit
2014
this is kind of odd this was created in
2014 but it was edited in 2016 that's
pretty well alright I mean I I think
still day created has got to be the way
to go so let's go with that will bring
in day created and we'll set that as the
date so let me see what format Oh
6:20
I'm not sure about that format there is
this what we want
now that that does not match up all
right so we're gonna have to do some
manipulating of this day created value
the other thing that we're gonna have to
deal with is this title so we've been
using the titles as the slugs for our
our posts and we see we were
manipulating that a little bit so that
it matched up with the current site I
don't think we're going to be able to
match things up with the current site
for all of these news articles I've been
looking at some of them and the the URLs
don't match with the titles and they're
not here in the database so I'm not sure
where they're stored or how to get those
or match them up so I'm not gonna try
we're just gonna have to live with that
we're gonna break some links I don't I
don't really see any way around that
other than having somebody go through
all of these and and change things
change the slug on WordPress manually I
may not if I find somebody that wants to
do that then that's okay but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna try that's just not
a good use of our time you know we've
other things to work on for this site I
just glanced at the live chat David says
remind yourself that overconfidence is a
slow and insidious killer all right good
advice
get it right I'm not sure where that
came from
am i coming off is really confident
today I don't know
let's see
all right let's go to
where we have our that's it there we go
okay so we're gonna have to change our
migrated J s and let's put this right
beside our C corporation studio screen
so here's where we've been importing
things here's where we put our query
alright so I do have de created and I'm
also pulling in the content teaser and
we're gonna make this the excerpt for
the post I think it will be useful to
bring in that same excerpt and then we
can try to use that as well if we have
you know like a small view maybe on the
front page of the website
before you can click to get the full
content so this query should give us all
the info we need now we need to change a
bit here
right so so right now we're saying name
equals post content title that's because
we originally made this when we're
bringing over the data for faculty
members probably be more straightforward
just to keep this as title but for now
I'm gonna leave it but here's what we do
have that I think we ought to get rid of
in here where you are checking for
titles in the in the slugs
so like dr. you know things like that we
didn't want them to keep the URLs the
same we had to get rid of them
but we don't want to do that for here
for one thing we're not worried about
keeping the URL is the same for you know
for another thing we would actually want
those words in these titles alright so
we're gonna just comment this out for
now and what we still want is to make
everything lowercase and to replace
spaces with hyphens all right so that
should make sense
we'll bring everything over we will need
to add let's add a excerpt you know
let's check out the API documentation
make sure we can add in an excerpt there
we go
excerpt
so we're going to bring in toast dots
where we call that content teaser
all right so the only thing we have left
that we do want to bring in is that date
so let's figure out how we can adjust
this date properly
let's look up
our date formats trying to find mdn yeah
all right so this is the format that we
want
I'm gonna sorry I know this is boring on
the stream but I'm gonna have to look at
this this a bit
we need this day to work
all right let's do some testing all
right so let me just grab a date in this
format can I copy this copy and let's
open up dev tools and let's do well
let's let's make this bigger and go to
console let's get rid of this stuff and
let's say what you what test dates equal
new dates and let's put that in
yes days
okay
all right so we can take this data in
and this this date works for the
JavaScript date but this is still not
what we want so let's see about that ISO
format let's see if we can far as
superposition of the date returns in
analysis
it's a tie soon all right there you go
let's go
just check this one out this looks like
what we need new date right and event 2
ISO string all right let's try it out
yeah
Oh No let's see if we can get that back
there we go and let's see the ISO date
equal test dates dots
- ISO string and then ISO date is
alright that looks like what we need
let's just double check to verify yep
that looks like what we need all right
cool so we can manipulate manipulate the
day to get what we want so let's take
what we've done here and put it into our
migrate jeaious looks like there is
there some confusion in the live chat so
let me just take a second to clarify
what's going on all right so Peter
welcome back I did switch to visual
studio everybody kept recommending it it
was fast so I thought let's try it out
Steven migrate Jas is just a it's a
little bit of node script so a little
bit of JavaScript that's helping us take
data out of one database kind of convert
the data into a format that we want and
then sending that into a different
database through WordPress so that's all
we're doing here we can do we have this
on github I'm not sure if I have this
repository on github it was on github
originally I haven't really been sinking
things up because we frequently change
this so anyway that but that's all that
we're doing here and Klaus says a black
screen so is anybody else having
problems with the screen being black on
my end
let's see everything is saying it's good
on my end so just let me know all right
so let's let's do some some work on this
date here so let's say
I so date let's see how much we could
put in line intervals ISO dates equals
posts new date and this B post thoughts
they created and then we're gonna go to
ISO string all right not sure if that'll
all work in line like that but let's
let's try it out and then let's
[Music]
I guess let's just try it let's try it
in the console first because I don't
want to run this and have it transfer
over bad data so let's just grab this
and we can take this day this test date
and put it in here and let's change this
to ISO date too okay so that does what
we wanted to it should work awesome
all right so just to just kind of recap
what we're doing we're taking the date
in one format which is a different
format than we need and we're making a
variable here constant we're getting
that date and we're making it into you
know like a JavaScript date what do you
call this a date object I don't know
what the correct term would be for that
but then we're taking that and we're
converting that to I so string so it's I
so I forget already what it was
[Music]
ISO 8601 format which is what we need
and then we're going to take that and
we're gonna add that in as the date so
the date will be ISO dates and I'm gonna
verify that date is what we want here so
let's check the docs and it is date we
want to date and it is a string ISO
format great all right so everything
should work let me check my time all
right six minutes cool close in about
six minutes I'm gonna take a break and
I'm gonna go to the live chat and
explain things so if you can hold on for
a few more minutes I'll explain I'll
explain everything just to give you
something for now this is a project that
I'm doing for my job as a front-end
developer and we're just kind of working
through it live together so that's the
like big picture of what what is going
on here also welcome thanks for watching
all right so let me give it one look
through just to make sure we're doing
the right thing so we're getting Content
ID title the actual content HTML day
created content
good from folder ID 89 and we wanted
this data length here we're saying we
don't want content that has no no data
on Stu are directors oh I'm glad I check
this right we don't want this to be in
directory we want it to be in news and I
don't know if we've actually created
that custom post type yet that would
have been a huge problem if I had just
let that go through there we go so who
was at the beginning to talk about over
con so David thank you for bringing up
overconfidence because if I had been
overconfident I would have just hit
enter on that thing and ran it and would
have messed things up
all right so it's so easy even when
you're not live-streaming it's so easy
to make a little mistake like that and
I've certainly made plenty of them on
the live stream but you know also when
I'm not streaming make little mistakes
all right that looks good now what we
need to do is make a post type that's
news so let's go with oops here's our
post type so this is just a PHP file
that is in the proper format to be a
wordpress plugin so we're gonna edit
this a bit see what we have directories
all right so let's copy
although I want to make sure I only copy
what I should be copying okay let's just
copy this and paste it and then we'll
change what we need to to make a new
news custom post type so we don't
normally use PHP on this stream but
occasionally we we do need to use it
mostly just when we're working with
WordPress so first of all let's just
change the word directory everywhere
where we find it
oops you know what I don't want to go
down that Fork is I want to keep the
uppercase stuff uppercase directory
let's say
all right that's fine it's a little bit
awkward to say add new news or something
like that but I I dragged it short than
say something like news story or news
items or something it's just easier to
work with one word now we have I guess
the singular and plural for news is the
same right
I mean it is right I'm not going crazy
there is it's just news whether singular
plural is no we don't say news is right
all right so let's just say news and
then for directory news and then one
more for directories we'll change it to
news all right so just really quickly
what's going on this part is basically
saying how do we want this to appear in
the WordPress admin panel so these are
all the labels that a user would see if
they were going in to edit the posts
through that admin panel down here is
more of how is this going to appear and
act you know kind of in the backend in
the API with graph QL you know things
like that
so that's what we're kind of saying like
well what things this is support and
some that like served title yeah this
looks good we do a nice clue from search
ability type news we want to show this
is going to show it in the REST API but
then also it's going to show it in the
graph QL that so we're using a graph WP
graph QL plug-in that's key that
basically lets us use graph QL with
WordPress that's how we're gonna grab it
from from this news here let's save that
and let's copy it and my timers up all
right so my time is up so we'll have
some suspense now here when we come back
from the five minute break then we will
update our plug-in and try to pull in
all this data all right this is going to
be a lot of data we're pulling it at
once so if we mess it up we have to go
in and try to delete it all and redo it
so I'm a little bit nervous about this
one
but we've double and triple-checked
everything so I think it'll be okay but
rather not mess up that much data so let
me take a short break here and go to the
live chat and answer some questions and
it looks like we've got a few more
viewers here in the last few minutes so
hey everyone thanks for watching feel
free to ask any questions in the latch
at
all right so Klaus had asked a few
minutes ago
for an explanation of what's going on
because it was the first time you know
seeing it so this is so to start from
from the beginning this is a project
that I am doing for work I'm a front-end
developer and so this is a real-life
project we're working on it's a react
basically it's it's react combined with
a WordPress back-end so data is going to
be put into WordPress you know from the
admin panel at some point right now
we're kind of doing a programmatic way
but later on people will be able to edit
this I then will pull that data with
graph QL into our react app and it would
be displayed there so we're doing a
little bit everything in this project
some streams we do like user interface
work sometimes you know we're building
react components we're working on
pulling in data from our API other times
like now we're working on you know
WordPress plugins post type database
things so there's a lot that's going
into it later on we'll get into setting
up our servers
there's we're still considering the
options in terms of how to set up the
servers and what to use but we're gonna
have to do all that so that's the
project that's what we're doing so today
specifically we're pretty much just
working with data if we get all the data
over and we have time maybe we'll worry
about like building out a new react
component and maybe like doing some
really basic styling of that and as a
follow up closest a wordpress site
builder three-act yet so kind of so I
would say it's a react site but we're
pulling in data from
WordPress right so that's going to be
one of the places we pull in data we may
end up pulling in data from multiple
sources for now most of the data is
going into WordPress and that's
basically it's just WordPress is
reliable there's a big community and a
lot of people know how to work with it
it's gonna be user friendly for the
people that need to edit the data that
don't necessarily know anything about
coding all right so hopefully that was a
decent explanation you can always go
back and check some of the previous
streams if you want to know more I think
the first stream I went in more depth
into explaining everything
let's see ghost sniper says I hate
coding and it'll never help me in life
and my school makes me do it I don't
know I guess it depends right if if you
if you never use a computer again I
don't know maybe it won't help that much
but you know it does teach some concepts
that could be helpful so school makes
you learn a lot of stuff you probably
don't want to do I know it did for me
and there is honestly a lot of stuff
that I learned in school that I haven't
ever used and I probably won't ever use
right I learned how to square dance in
school I never square dance before
I'm nervous square dance after that ever
so totally totally not needed I took
acting classes in school for a couple
years and I'm not an actor right so I
don't know it is what it is
but I asked oh you can do is control how
you react to being able to having to
learn how to code you can control your
attitude and how you feel about it
so try to make the best of it and to be
honest you can make a ton of money
coding at some point so it's it's not so
bad that you're learning it
let's see reading one more question John
Hanson says anyone having a hard time
understanding event propagation and
create react app I am is it a best
prayer
just to use it to stop a parent
eventlistener to add this on to all
children objects with events um I'm a
little bit interested ideas shouldn't
let me see some of the code so I'm just
wondering about using like event stop
propagation is that the best way to do
it and react I'm not sure I personally
haven't used it in anything with react
so I don't know that I could give a good
answer for that but I would be
interested to see if there is maybe a
unique react type of way to handle that
and do something like that that would
make things easier but sorry John I
Kissed can't I don't have experience
with it so hope maybe somebody else
knows if anybody that's listening right
now or watching knows about stopping
event propagation with react please
share your knowledge in the live chat
alright so I didn't get through all the
questions a live chat but I will come
back to the live chat after we do a bit
more with our data
alright either write down what question
I left off with so I remember later on
alright let's restart our timer and now
all that's left to do is move this into
our WordPress installation or plugin
right let's update our plugin and we'll
move that data over we'll run our our
node program here our migrate j/s and
see if it works
so where's I thought I was logged in I
am loved in here alright so we'll go to
our plugins to our editor and we can
select our our custom types plug-in that
we've created and now paste it and
update the file cool alright no weird
errors when we did that and lets you
know what let's double check there we
are okay just wanted to make sure we did
in fact have news let's make sure that
we have a title like search the featured
image wonderful alright so don't really
want to add a new one so once we
transfer this data we should be able to
see a ton of news items here news posts
so let's do that now let me make sure
I'm on the right network okay I'm on the
right network I can only access the
database from one network and right IP
address and everything so I know I
talked about making a copy of the
database to get around that I just I
never did it
so still probably a good idea to do
all right so let's see it's not as
opening would save it
No
let's see what did we get a range error
Oh
all right let's see what happened check
this out first verify that nothing came
through right nothing came through we
have some sort of error here so let's
check it out
I don't know promise rejection warning
rejection t1 Ranger invalid time value
you
let's see
all right the ISO date your data is a
string literal not the date string all
right so my data coming through is not
what we want to put in there
is that correct
we see
oh I see now truck thank you thank you I
can't believe I did that
alright thanks for catching that we even
checked how many times did we check and
I still missed it
all right yeah so I was trying to pass
in a string that said post date
underscore created instead of actually
the the variable the value thankfully it
didn't actually go through and it was
rejected by WordPress or that that could
have been a mess all right
so rookies the hero of the day thank you
again
let's stop this program now and rerun it
whoa there we go it's inserting a lot of
hoes
I've always been interested in like how
many posts I could insert at once I'm
gonna find out now because I think this
is the largest block the largest content
type that we will have to bring over so
if this works I don't have any worries
about anything else
all right slowing down a little bit
whoa did you just see that jump it was
frozen for a second and then all of a
sudden it just jumped from 400 to 500
all right we'll let it let it do its
thing
yes
at one time at one point I had thought
about putting a delay and I don't know
if we ever did that like a delay between
attempts to add things
you
maybe it finished
it's possible that it finished 546 rows
546 it did alright cool it finished I'm
here I'm waiting and nothing because it
finished all right cool let's check it
out
so here's the the big test let's see if
it works
oh there we are awesome
very awesome so we have an excerpt weird
format but still excerpts we have the
HTML came through the title let's see
the slug I'm really interested to see
how the slug came through alright
awesome that looks nice
cancer scientists gather for the Jubilee
kasam oh whoa
all right we have a little bit of a
problem here
all right I don't know if you'll see
this it's really small let me zoom in a
bit why is the slug filled in WordPress
this short anyway let's go over
everything looks good until we get here
and there are spaces in the middle of a
word and a hyphen
why why would we have that
let's see if this is
you would so what are titles look like
all right let's see what we were doing
here so all we're doing
whose content title moving everything a
lowercase and we're replacing spaces
that's really odd I'm gonna check just a
few other posts just to see if I can
find some similarity as to how this
happened because I mean obviously we can
see the title here oops
you know it doesn't look like anything's
wrong here with the title so let's just
check a few more items and let's check
I'm just going through really quickly I
might write a plug-in that makes this
slug feel of larger that's just insane
that really bugs me
you all know I'm pretty easygoing most
of the time but that's like that's
terrible what like that's just a
terrible UI anyway all right I didn't
check to I didn't think to check the
permalink to see if the same problem in
the permalink which I think we would so
let me go back to this one and see look
at that so that with the permalink it
doesn't have that problem that's really
odd
let's see summer conference sessions so
in these even have the same word in it
so if we still have the same word
conference none of them have that
problem all right I'm not going to worry
about it right now but what we're gonna
what I do want to double check is these
published dates to make sure all right
so we do have different dates well 28
pages I want to go to the last page
right awesome 2014 18 minutes news one
all right so they did bring in so just
some some kind of nonsense posts we can
clean that up later I'm not worried
about it but this is really cool that's
really cool we have all the stuff family
alright so now we need to display it let
me check my time alright 11 minutes
let's go over to the react side of
things and see if we can pull this data
in so we'll need we need to make it a
graph QL query will have to do another
one I know we did one yesterday we'll do
one today it shouldn't be too hard we
can
probably copy and paste most of what we
did yesterday if not everything and then
we'll we could probably reuse a lot of
the same react component that we use
yesterday as well and just change some
of the names so we may be able to do
this in in 11 minutes and I see there's
some some comments in the lodge actually
there's there's some pertinent comments
here let me get to these edy Edward says
it's not supposed to be like this did
you delete the slug to create it it's
gonna populate a field automatically we
let's see let me show you our adding the
slug in so I'm I'm adding the slug
manually when we update these so the
reason we were doing this you're
actually right it would have made this
love automatically from the title that
might have been a better way to go oh
well I'm not gonna try to redo all that
now but that probably would have been a
better way to go the reason we were
adding the slug before is because we we
did want to manipulate the slug
previously to try to make the URLs match
up between what we currently have and
what we are going to have later in this
case we didn't need to do that so I just
didn't even think about it we it had
just been left in previously so that's a
really good point though thanks for
bringing that up
I'll keep that in mind when we pull over
more data that this is not necessary
unless we we really need to change with
the slug all day maybe we could avoid
some errors you know potentially we have
an error already in there
I once we get everything worked out I
want to try to type in this in a URL and
see what data we can get I'm interested
to see what what happens with that
all right so let's go to our yes sir
Aparna Paulo is just sit yeah this is it
all right cool so we need to go to let's
take this and we just duplicate No
all right let's grab this and make a new
query new file we'll call it we're gonna
call this news dodge as I'm gonna paste
in this we're gonna change it some news
news query we're going to change this to
news all right so this should grab our
ID our title the slug the content and do
we want
let's grab the excerpt as well and the
dates alright yeah we're gonna we're
gonna grab this we may not actually need
the date it might already be with within
the HTML but just to be safe we'll grab
it it'll actually be good to have it
because if we want to make a news page
and order things chronologically then it
would be we definitely need a date to
make that work and all right cool
so we have this say that let's go into
our pages and we're gonna take let's
take our directory and just copy it and
let's make another page you know that
these are really react components but in
terms of next j/s which we are also
using the their their pages in this case
it's acts more like a template for a
page but you'll see you'll see how it's
how it's all going to work and we'll
also name this news das there we are and
let's change this change the word
directory everywhere remember this well
if you remember yesterday I forgot this
part we had an error to news
this is fine for now this will prove
that we're actually getting the data and
then we can see if we want to display
anything else like the date or something
like that
all right let's save that now we need to
go into our server as well just going to
server Jas and let me let me give you
the link to our end Rock server so you
all can see it as we're working on it
and and you can see the data coming in
as well so if you check that link
sometimes there's weird problems with
links so you might have to copy and
paste the link to get it to work but
hopefully you don't it looks like it's
working so all right awesome sorry I
didn't give you that link earlier we
didn't really need it and so now because
we weren't doing anything directly with
with the UI for the the react site but
in any case now you all have it we're
gonna take this little block here and
we're just going to copy and paste that
and instead of contact we're gonna say
news and we're gonna say news here let
me explain what's going on here
let's make this a bit bigger all right
so here's what's happening we're saying
that when a user types in URL that has /
news / whatever at the end so you know
any value what we're gonna do is we're
gonna pass that value at the end we're
gonna pass that into the component and
the component that we're gonna pass it
to is going to be the news component
right so that's what we want to do so
let's save that and then in our news
component we're grabbing that so we get
this query ID we're grabbing that here
in this get initial props function this
is going to be able to run server side
and clients
this is a special function that next
jazz has so that's why we're grabbing
things here grabbing the proper data so
we can get that nice server-side
rendering we don't really need the
console log here I just had that there
for testing probably ought to take this
out and let's see all right looks like
oh okay so once we grab that ID what we
were trying to get from graph QL is
we're going to use that news query and
we're gonna pass it that ID all right
which is basically the slub from our
wordpress post then since we're calling
on that news query let's go up here and
check it out so the news query comes in
and what are we passing in this name all
right which is the ID that's our slug so
it's going to look for a news item where
the name is equal to that slug so that's
what it's going and it's going to return
all of this data ID title slug content
excerpt and date it's going to return
all of that into into this component
right so it'll go back to the component
of news j/s and then it's going to put
that data in in here and rook you are on
top of things because rook notice that i
forgot to change directories here thank
you again so you see where we're getting
that object so we're there's now an
object available to us your data news
edges we're a zero right so the edges is
an array we want the first value node
content and that matches up with our
news here right edges node
content right alright so now we have
that here let me see I'm not sure if I
need to restart the server or not let's
do it just to be safe or actually no
once you're in used up you slash
whatever it looks like some of you were
trying to look up the news page right
now alright so that should restart and I
need to find the slug to try so let's
try one that'll probably work because
it's normal and then we'll try one that
that first one that has some weird stuff
going on all right so let's go back here
and say use slash what the heck it's a
sad
do that server come back up yeah all
right / news / all right that's far so
it's not about graph QL document node
you may got killed off sooner in another
method native documents see what's
happened
let's go back to our code I did it say
pages I so unfortunately we don't have
the correct line because it's using the
I guess a different version of this
let's see my timer just went off I kind
of want to I wanted to see if this would
work first all right let me go back and
answer some questions and I will take
five minutes and then we'll go back to
it and try to troubleshoot see what's
going on
probably it just messed something up
when I was changing things over from
news to from directory to news but we'll
see there might be something wrong with
with our data we'll figure that out for
now let me chat a bit with you all I'm
gonna chat for five minutes with you
then I'm gonna check and make sure
nothing has come through on slack or my
email that I need to handle for work if
everything is good then we're gonna
figure this up
let's see alright so John Hanson says
with next jazz is it then not necessary
to install or use reactor outer yeah you
don't need to install or use react
router with next
so we're basically doing our own custom
routing and here alright so this is some
some custom routes so we're just kind of
doing her own thing I did see a tweet
from I can't remember his name
Guillermo I think his name is
anyway I wait from he's like the the
head of site which makes next I saw a
tweet about the next version of next is
going to actually incorporate react
router into it so I'm not sure how
that's gonna work I didn't look into it
but I figure at some point we'll
probably be using the newer version so
I'll have to learn it that would that
would be kind of cool I think would be
nice to have the same type of routing
across everything we're building since
we're using react router for you know
art or other stuff that we made with
create react app let's see dip back says
hey Jesse this is my first free code
camp live stream what app are you using
for your databases is it free you're
doing great thanks for doing this most
appreciated you're welcome I appreciate
the comment yeah let me show you what
we're using for the database so this is
sequel operations studio let's see how
you get yeah sequel operation studio
from Microsoft it is entirely free it's
free to download and it's it's an
electron app it's built with JavaScript
HTML so it's very similar in the way
it's built and even in the UI to Visual
Studio code you know you can see a lot
of you know kind of a similarities here
same icons same layout things like that
so that's what we're using
I really like it I'm not a database
person so I don't have much to compare
it to other than like I don't like PHP
myadmin or whatever is called or my PHP
admin I don't know what that is but I
like it a lot better than that and also
thanks for watching and welcome to the
stream all right says sooraj says what
do you do to select multiple words and
update at once the visual studio code oh
cool the multiple cursor thing I love
this it's so cool so let's just let's go
to query params here and I highlight
what I want to select and if there's
anything else below it that is the same
I just hit command I'm on a Mac so I hit
command D I assumed it would be control
D on Windows but I'm not sure and then I
just every time I hit D it selects
something new and then I can go in here
and I can add whatever I want
backspace and I could even move the
cursor around with the left and right
arrow keys even I can go down with a
down arrow key or up so really cool and
useful when you don't need the power of
a Find and Replace and there's just a
few things that you need to change it's
faster than finding replace at least it
is for me so I really like it I will say
though that I'm using the key bindings
for the atom editor because I switched
from atom to here so I don't know what
the default is for visual studio code it
might be different so I would check
check that out
you know just check the documentation it
might might be different
coding and caffeine says hello its me I
was wondering if some of you wanted a
cup of coffee I actually do want a cup
of coffee so I have I've had a lot of
caffeine already today I guess I had a
double espresso this morning I had some
G fuel and remember G fuel you can
sponsor me but add some G fuel before
the dream to help me get kind of pumped
up otherwise I seem depressed on the
strain so but I'd still like more coffee
I'm pretty much always gonna say yes the
coffee if somebody offers C I'm just the
my timer went up I'm just checking cuz
I'm almost at the end of the live chat
John said kick can the [ __ ] generated
from another better source like a
pendant number I don't I don't know I I
tried to look for something better but I
think the title is the title makes sense
to use I'm just I'm gonna go with that
Michael asked what is the visual studio
code plug-in that adds the file size on
the import statements let me share a
link with you all
so hopefully this works you may have to
copy and paste it because links are
weird sometimes in the YouTube live chat
but there's a plug-in called the react
food truck and it actually just pulls in
a lot of other plugins that have to do
with react so that's how I got it
initially if you just want the one
plug-in let me look up the name for you
it is import cost so the plug-in is
called imports cost and I can send I can
give you the direct link to that as well
so here's the link to that plug-in but
really cool though isn't it so you
automatically know you know what with
the plug-in and even is different like
this is 1.1 megabytes and it's in red so
I assume the red means hey this is a big
this is a big plug and this is a big
package that you're bringing in so it's
kind of cool I haven't really acted on
any of that yet but I imagine if I was
really trying to improve things and go
in that would be so helpful to just be
able to see right away like maybe I
don't need him for all of this
let me know if the stream status is okay
um it's telling me that it's bad right
now I'm not sure why but if the stream
starts getting weird just just let me
know I don't really know if I can do
anything about it
but I'd still like to know as soon as
did you make this website mobile
responsive its kind of responsive right
now I haven't really checked everything
out but it should be because we're using
material UI it's a handle like our
layout and everything so that's like by
default responsive but like I said I
haven't actually checked it on a phone
yet so I don't know for sure but we'll
do all that as as it gets you know we
get more things built out
alright let's let's figure out what the
problem is here so alright let's first
let's look at server let's make sure
News we're sending it to news all right
that looks that's good as it should be
let's just start at the top and make
sure oops there we are there's the
problem we want to take it from the news
directory I can't believe I remembered
this part and forget this part again did
the same thing yesterday
alright let's save that now and try
again let's refresh hey there we go
oh let's see this is a bit of a mess wow
wow wow
Wow
that looks pretty bad
Don Xavier says the links aren't working
that I posted you may have to just copy
and paste the links because when you
when you put a link in the YouTube live
chat YouTube actually is like redirects
you to it and so it doesn't always work
so I would try try that try to copy and
paste or something it the links work I
just went to them but just not if you
click it inside the live chat all right
all right let me ask you all do you want
me to start styling this right now or do
you think we've had it long enough
stream we should save it till tomorrow
or some other time I'll give everybody
just I'll give everybody a minute to
respond while I check my work slack and
email since I forgot to do that
alright nothing on slack that I need to
worry about let's see
nothing in my email
alright looks good looks like we're good
to go so if you all want me to keep
going I can let me keep going regardless
because I'm still at work and have to
work on it it's just a matter of whether
or not I stream what the work that I'm
about to do
see
all right so I haven't gotten a response
at all one way or another about whether
I should stream the rest of this let's
see we still have over 30 viewers so
looks like there's still some interest
all right I'm just going to keep going
and do some basic styling then all right
I had to change my song really quick and
I didn't like the song that was on can't
possibly do do coding without the right
music right all right so let's inspect
what we have see what we can do about it
all right so it looks like we have some
images
in the speakers in this place
you know what I did want to test out
that other one first let me do it before
I forget so we had that weird slug with
which one this one let's test it out
that's not it
wait a second that was the slug that had
the problem right
maybe it was a different one
no that was it that was the one other
problem maybe this one no all right I
don't know what happened but the problem
is not there anymore so that's good news
I'm gonna leave it alone all right so
let's check out this image
[Music]
let's try yes / /
that should work
I'm gonna put this in a browser on my
other screen see if anything comes up
it's not there anymore
ooh
all right
oh well so I'm not sure if we'll be able
to get the images so for now I need to
hide the image I'm not gonna worry about
the images now need to find these at
some point and figure out what to do
with them but let's see we should add
the title in here we already have the
date
what is all this stuff why do we have
the same thing repeated
news summary and related news summary
all right we need to get rid of these
all right so let's do some work on
getting rid of let's get rid of
everything we don't want first before we
try to style or add anything it'll
probably look a little easier if we
bring up bring the content down first
the amount of content so let's check
this let me look back as well at what we
did with this faculty because we did do
a lot of this type of work with the
faculty we did some manipulation here of
of the mark-up which we may want to do
that as well let's see
hmm I mean the easiest thing would be
probably just to do some CSS and hide it
with CSS right now so let's grab let's
actually get this CSS page and I I'm
probably will come up with a better way
to do CSS but at this point you know
this is how I'm going to do it styles
where am I putting my styles
hmm oh okay I'm bringing it in with this
static style so I can all right
alright oops and I forgot to set my
timer again and you do that alright so
I'm going to copy what I have here and
paste it as a start I realize that this
is not the way we want to do it
completely so maybe I'll make an issue
about figuring out what we're gonna do
with CSS and then stick with it I didn't
really want to decide till we started
importing more things and seeing like
what we were working with how much CSS
would we want to reuse how much would be
unique so we'll get a better idea now
that we have you know several different
content types
imported now alright so I'm going to
copy that and I'm gonna make another CSS
file and a new file we're gonna call it
news dot CSS and then obviously - I'd
much rather be doing sass and CSS this
what we have for now and then let's go
back to that faculty page and let's copy
this portion here and use it in our news
page
did we have it in layout let's see we
did and we also need to bring this in
and we had brought in grid as well I'm
not gonna bring that in yet though
because I'm not even sure if that worked
for us before yeah it's so much stuff
going on let's get rid of some of this I
want to save let's all right let's wait
let's hold off on that shares queries
directories there we are news you don't
need that or that or that
all right that's a lot more simple there
we are and we want to change this to be
news all right great
so let's let's see what we have now just
by bringing that CSS and I imagine we'll
have you know some some impact on how
this looks all right it's not bad
already it's better not 100% but better
for sure nice nice I like that
sweet
hey wait a second hey this actually this
article links to the website that we
built together the catechetical
stockholm site so that's pretty fun
alright let's add some things in here to
get rid of a lot of this stuff at the
top that we don't really need and then
we'll probably add in a title after that
oops
moved it over here alright so let's
check our CSS page and we need to check
the names again let's check the names
news summary I wonder if we can just get
rid of this whole thing
this whole first part why is the title
not showing up at all that's weird but
it's okay
Roots yeah let's just get rid of root
that'll solve all our problems
awesome we'll get rid of root at some
point we'll have to figure out what to
do about the image yeah I'm not sure but
for now we'll get rid of rude that'll
save us a lot of time trying to pick
through what we want and don't want and
then we'll add in a title on our own
instead of getting that title to show up
that that we saw in the markup so let's
go we're gonna do a display:none on that
that component that was called route
we're also gonna get rid of some of
these that I know we don't need so we
don't need a name or fun columns that's
fine
I don't know if we have a right column
or a center column we'll have to
double-check that heading it's
most of these we probably don't have I
wonder though if any of these would end
up having a video embed so I'm gonna
leave that in for now
all right so most of it we're gonna keep
and alright so let's let's see make
verify that this actually is gonna
remove what we want great it removed it
now let's add in a title so we're gonna
go with and see typography and then we
bring in typography in no we're not we
need to bring in typography we need to
bring it in we're not bringing in
anything from material UI well then we
bring it in here no wow
we definitely brought it in for our
index so let's check that typography so
always better to try to copy and paste
from somewhere that we know it works
right and so we're bringing that in and
I also want to check what the name of
alright display two subheading just way
to what did we use headline h2
so we use and did that work yeah let's
try it out
typography type headline component h2
we'll try it
every age - really it probably should be
an h3 but we'll we'll see actually let's
let's do it like this let's go
dangerous he said innerhtml you know
I'll explain in a second why I want to
do it this way is zero
title is a title or is it name let's
show
his title
why do we have a problem here
I'm missing
we
something I guess is something wrong
with the video let's see what's going on
all right this is weird
so OBS says that everything's fine but
YouTube's admin panel says the stream
status is bad for resolution alright I'm
not sure what's happening everybody let
me know everybody who can enlarge that
let me know if the stream is ok or if
it's bad if the quality's going bad I
might just end the stream because I
don't want there to be a bunch of you
know bad quality at the end of the video
all right so that's that's really weird
so this shows up it's fine
but I'm getting a weird error here
that's this for me
alright let's copy and paste this
I'm still getting something
that's weird
all right well it looks like the video
then is is no good so actually I think
I'm gonna stop here I mean if you look
at it this doesn't look bad right
the only so you all can't see but
basically if you can't see what's going
on let me explain everything looks fine
we've removed a lot of what we wanted to
remove we now have a proper title
it needs a line better with the rest of
the content the only thing that I would
add at this point is a date so I would
add the date somewhere in here probably
at the top and that's really about it
maybe I would change the link color
possibly make the font size a bit bigger
but that's it so alright so let me let
me wrap things up then I'm gonna check
the live chat quickly to see if there
are any comments that I should respond
to since it doesn't really matter for if
I have video for that let's see
all right
let's see John Hanson says my son
challenged me to build a react component
ever play with a toy called lite-brite
it uses touch and mouse events give it a
try
no way John did you build lite-brite in
react I have got to check this out
I wish my video wasn't first and I would
show everybody what you made
well I'll try to show everybody anyway
if the video comes back in I guess I can
see it hopefully this URL works you know
how it is sometimes with the the YouTube
stuff even if you put it in like this
sometimes it still doesn't work yes
Oh John this is amazing all right you
all probably can't see this light bright
thing but you look you have to check it
out I'm gonna paste the the URL in the
chat as well Wow Wow this is so cool
I'm showing my kids when I get home I
want to bring this up on my my
Chromebook his touchscreen this would be
so cool with just to be able to touch it
Wow John amazing amazing work that's the
that's the coolest thing I've seen in a
while
wow that's awesome I love it when stuff
like this happens on the stream y'all
are like so creative and I love it when
you share stuff like that
Rick Adams has just read a LinkedIn TM
for a front-end function for Monday
given my focus is more back in which
qualitative suggests in front-end design
video tours are recommended
for front-end stuff I mean you could
check out check check out some of the
videos here on the free code camp
channel it's on a lot of different
topics so just kind of sift through some
of them there's a YouTube channel called
dev tips de VT IPs and the videos are
kind of older but a lot of really good
stuff about you know front-end work so
check that out I don't think what else I
would go with Udacity has some front-end
courses that are free and there's a lot
of video content in those courses so you
can check that out as well
all right world says does graph QL lets
you query any random website or does
that website need that graph QL already
configured that website needs to have
graph QL already configured think of it
like a REST API right you you'd have to
someone would have to build the REST API
for you to be able to use it it's the
same thing with graph QL they would have
to build the graph QL API is that safe
to call a graph QL API way it functions
like that right I mean I know it's it's
graph query language anyway someone
would have to build that out just like
they would arrest API that's a good
question though the video came back oh
cool John said to drag my mouse on the
board oh oh that's so cool oh man johner
is it cool if I share this with a bunch
of people because this is really I mean
I'll definitely give you all the credit
but this is awesome I used to love lite
brite when I was a kid this is really
cold
all right Mandela says you need to
restart the stream if it happens next
time YouTube can give me a thousand for
console fee yeah oh maybe I should have
just restarted right away I will
remember that for next time
are let me when outlive the videos back
let me switch back quickly to here this
is what I was talking about right we
have all our paragraphs here it's the
right font I think it needs to be a bit
bigger like font size but same way with
the title title needs to be a bit bigger
and it needs to be aligned properly but
like I said it's not bad looks good just
needs the only I would add would be the
date but not bad at all at some point it
might be cool to include categories and
people could click and sort by
categories but I'm not worried about
that right now that would be additional
functionality that we could add in once
that data did get entered all right cool
this will be fun I think I might share
this my boss has been really busy with
some other stuff so he still hasn't had
a chance to review any of the work we've
done so far so I'm gonna let him handle
his stuff and whenever things calm down
a bit then maybe I'll show this to him
but maybe I'll share it with some of my
other co-workers so I can get some early
feedback and you know see if everyone
thanks for warned in the right direction
all right awesome
so I'm gonna wrap things up now it's
been a longer than normal stream but
really fun we've gotten a lot done we
didn't mess things up
I messed them up a little bit but they
were really easy errors too to overcome
and we got a ton of data imported into
WordPress like over 500 will you call
them records right so we have over 500
posts under the news post type and when
we started that post I didn't even exist
in our WordPress install so not only did
we get a new post type and all the data
in but now we're actually displaying it
properly with the proper parameters
routing but all the infos there needs a
bit of work on the styling but overall
I'm really happy with today's
cool good work everyone and thank you so
much everybody for your help especially
rook for catching two of my mistakes and
saving saving me a lot of time and
thanks John for sharing your lite-brite
app that's amazing I'm gonna be sharing
it with other people as well and thanks
everyone else too that was it a live
chat and if you're watching later on you
can participate in the live chat but you
have questions you know please put them
in the comments for the video or you can
you know message me on Twitter my DMS
are open you could message me there or
any other social media that that you
like to use I'm on pretty much
everything let's see oh and don't forget
to check out my new video on my channel
about my Udacity react nanodegree
experience so I'll be back tomorrow
until then have a great day